per tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessimo
video sono fa vj mi stavo uccidendo con
questo oggi siamo sul mostrum che ho
trovato su steam che dovrebbe essere una
file faccia new game
la partenza a caso dai 23 screen che ho
visto dovrebbe essere una figata
pazzesca poi magari una cagata
e in quel caso ti do in pasto ai panda
senza paratie per non si sa ovviamente
come cazzo ci siamo finiti quattro o due
gambe dovrebbe essere un gioco dove sono
su una nave una nave f to open the man
armadietto questo è la madonna che cosa
stai facendo qui dentro di preciso
magari sistema smanettando il birillo
ragazzi quindi evitiamo di andare a
fondo il carica batteria dell'iphone
lopresto secondo me saldo in testa
qualcuno gli fa male una torcia perfetto
ok ragazzi siamo partiti non so neanche
dove devo andare lì preciso però va bene
perfetto ma che belle scale poco piene
di ruggine che bei che sono questi ma se
essa non è abbandonata che il caso serve
una telecamera di preciso votiamo cene
altamente a si può uscire
fantastico no è una figata assurdo
bellissimo stiamo leggermente messi male
ad onde ma tanto non guido io quindi
frattese gara possono scopelliti motivo
outlast c'è un obiettivo in questo gioco
devo andare a casa of it e un elicottero
scopri dove sei picchia riguarda non
l'ho mica capito ancora bisogno di
carburante forse possono scappare trova
le chiavi quella roba lì e trova una
pompa perfetto c'è un tabaccaio da
qualche parte dove compro le cose non so
dove posso andare a prendere queste cose
però io ho un caricabatterie mi serve
della benzina grazie possibilmente sì
che botta di culo rumori orribili anche
una tazza del caffè fantastico sì ho
rotto una tazzina da caffè madonna come
sono
[Musica]
che c'è del plus un container cosa
mischia dovrebbe essere questa cosa una
crema idratante quota
non lo so ragazzi ragazzo via via via
via via via via via via via via via
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce veloce lega dove
cazzo stornandoli anno non arrivato di
quando arrivato di vari altri cori
orticola merda sono in trappola statevi
sopra veloce cazzo però che botta di
culo mi sono salvato ragazzi sono
cos'era quella merda ho trovato un mi
sembrano smigol tipo non ho capito che
cos'era ma non mi interessa sincera mare
è andato dove l'obiettivo è quello di
trovare le cose tipo per scappare no
perfetto lo provocata sono un [ __ ]
genio reagan non so come fa fatemi
chiudere perché c'è un po di ca ga
leggermente devo capire un attimo ancora
dove cos'è c'è arsi fumoni oddio
fantastico questo trovato side batteri
fantasmi carica mi manca una cosa in
croce poi possono scappare di qua eh va
beh ma un po più piano magari anche tu a
ragazzi mi stanno premendo pericolo
[ __ ] via via via via via via via
via via dove devo andare dove doveva ndo
cazzo
va bene così perché io amo questo
[ __ ] gioco non vedevo la sea
nell'armadietto veloce chiudi perfetto
arrivo non entro nei ragazzi non entra
col sesso perché è uscito smigol da una
pustola della carta igeano n 1 tazza ma
io posso dire in faccia la tazza il
bello è che sembra che se andando
tranquillo in giro per la nave con la
tazza di caffè pero in realtà voglio
tirare addosso
grazie a dio sono fu e non ce la potevo
più fare posso buttare una tazza nel
mare che magari qualcuno mi trovo ho
trovato della benzina che non saper
niente dove metterla però io faccio così
esattamente così si darà benzina alle
coop effettuano finita ho trovato della
coca cola che non so che grande è roba
da gettare addosso alla gente fantastico
è la madonna che cazzo è successo no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no l nella pigra
marchiava [ __ ] via di qui prende
per il culo quando esce poi non c'è più
credo cos'è quando dove merda ma
[ __ ] e chiudi per favore grafica
con le apre le porte a uno e capace che
ce lo devi morire male sto lanciato
dall'aiom ne vuoi sapere zio ti do da
bere non ti do da bere non ti do d'avere
sto scherzando scherzando ragazzi
ragazzi è quanto sei prodotto da un 227
rilancio qualsiasi cosa e non muore
potrebbe essere un problema tipo mia
madre quando prendevo i due a scuola
rincorreva anche peggio ragazzi no no no
sono incastrato per dare chiudi però
prega perché hanno nonna che apra le
porte cazzo apre le porte ma io lo so
che apre le porte ha aperto la porta è
la madonna ma che cosa sei ragazzi
perché
mia amica mi sono salvato per miracolo
dove rifiuti chiudi chiudi più di jesi
in salvo mentre sta merda bravo più di
tutto perfetto
ragazzi sta entrando insegna apre la
porta al tiro giù i santi spegne la luce
[Musica]
e invece cosa ogni zio chiedo è perché
siamo tutti contenti senza smetti di
dirottare a liberamente una grazia che
hai pestato merda che è successo è
andato a minchia non solo posso uscire
non si apre più rapporto sono muoio qua
dentro il fisso come si apre la porta
potrebbe essere un problema è che bene
così adoro questo gioco ragazzi se non
si fosse capito meraviglioso devo andare
per forza qua dentro perché l'unico
punto che ancora non ho visto non l'ho
visto perché l'ultima volta mi è sceso
dalle scale quel pezzente quindi
potrebbe essere un problema devo trovare
un estintore
come faccio l'in esempio posso usarlo
fuck yeah e maledizione
questo è successo sono inciampato su c'è
un buco a terra fantastico no no no no
no no però ragazzino la toilette e la
toilette la toilette si apre la toilette
mi fate cadere addosso grazie perfetto
utilizzando la la la la scialuppa di
salvataggio dove essa solo un po di sana
dove ragazze mi ha visto mi ha visto mi
ha visto adesso si si si si si raffredda
la mamma mia via via via via via via i
ragazzi mi ha visto sono nella merda e
vabbè pazienza
ascoltate un attimo ho trovato un altro
modo di scappare che non ho capito qual
è non aprire una prima fare un cazzo via
via via via via via subito
qua dove devo andare ragazzi dove devo
andare merda posso buttarmi giù no vero
sì sì no sì sì o no si sono sono caduto
due metri ma non è vero ma come una
radio trovato una cazzo di radio
ma chi è ad ora roma prima questa cosa
adesso vado in giro a fare james a cork
con lo stereo che con successo era
quella roba o cristo gesù ragazzi è la
madonna chi cazzo sei ma doveva aveva un
po più grosso ma certo seriamente
ragazzi un po più grosso la prossima
volta
ancora mi dicevo che non corre non è
leggermente un'esagerazione mettere un
colosso così secondo me ce l'hai piccolo
anche non sento l'odore della lasagna
digerita l'altro ieri o sento già
chiesta gente bruttissimo si può vivere
così comunque no non ce la puoi fare
ma vorrei che schifo ce la puoi fare a
far benzina non è difficile
cosa dove quando perché della benzina da
regalo della regalo te la regalo te la
regalo anche del nastro arancione
questa e una batteria per il sottomarino
questo un fusibile questa è la sveglia
della mamma via cazzo possono anni poco
che esplode non esplode non esplode
nella squadra mi sun incastrato unica
ragazzi mi sono incastrati schiuma
strumenti che valgo che paghi
incredibile no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no non mi ha
preso che brutto culo amico mio però la
watson uscito sono semplici astratto
[ __ ] sei una merda
non so poi così brutto perché le buone
maniere proprio zero ragazzi lascio
perdere perché è impossibile
sono riuscito una volta a trovarli tutti
i pezzi e indecente comunque se pensate
anche voi che sia un figo ma ma tanto
processo
vabbè ever crombie lasciate un commento
mi piace anche a pagine di facebook e
come non invitato a tale descrizione se
ne vorresti di silente che ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi